tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel à
minuit ce soir hausse de 3 centimes de
l'essence du fuel et du gazole le gaz
augmente lui de 9,3 pour cent
échec de la conférence européenne de
dublin pour éviter la rupture les neuf
se donnent rendez vous à bruxelles dans
trois mois
iran les fête de l'achoura marque le
triomphe de kobenni le chat cherche
toujours un pays d'accueil la rencontre
jean paul ii dimitrios premier un pas
vers une réunion possible de 800
millions de catholiques et 180 millions
d'orthodoxes bonsoir que faut-il faire
quand on ne s'entend décidément pas
quand une femme chef de gouvernement
résiste aussi bien que madame thatcher
que faut-il faire se séparer
définitivement cassé l'europe élargie ou
alors remettre ça à plus tard réfléchir
apprendre à s'aimer peut-être et as
toléré c'est la deuxième solution qui a
été choisie au sommet de dublin
on a frôlé la crise parce que la grande
bretagne ne veut toujours pas payé ce
qu'on lui demande au budget de la
communauté
on ne sait pas qui va payer le déficit
maintenant mais ce ne sera pas madame
thatcher
on se reverra en février n'y a donc pas
eu de divorce mais la conciliation a
échoué pour cette fois ci et on a pris
mille précautions pour que ce n'est pas
l'air dramatique mais pour les
agriculteurs français dès maintenant la
colère commence à gronder le nouveau
président de la fnsea françois guillaume
dit qu'à ce stade des négociations et
bien le départ de la grande bretagne
simplifierait les choses de dublin pour
l'instant jacques hébert margaret
thatcher avec son tempérament inflexible
d'un côté ses huit partenaires avec la
défense de leurs intérêts communs de
l'autre auront donc fait ici à dublin
la politique du bras de fer dans une
atmosphère dire à valéry giscard
d'estaing parfois proche de la rupture
oh certes dans l'histoire de l'europe ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on se
sépare sans avoir trouvé un accord et
que l'on reporte un problème délicat à
une date ultérieure
mais la crise ouverte ici à dublin sur
le problème de la contribution
britannique au budget de l'europe est
certainement l'une des plus graves de la
brève histoire des neuf dans les
couloirs du conseil européen
les mots les plus souvent prononcées
étaient ceux des chèques d'un pass ou de
blocage
car sur le problème précis de la
contribution on ne voit pas ce qui
pourrait faire changer d'avis tel ou tel
pays mais le chef de l'état français
pose une condition avant que se
réunissent un nouveau conseil sur le
sujet probablement fin février il faudra
que d'ici là a dit le chef de l'état on
et trouver des solutions à certains
problèmes communautaires comme celui du
mouton de la pêche ou de l'énergie
valéry giscard d'estaing ajoutera ceci
jusqu'au dernier moment margaret sa
chair a cru qu'elle l'emporterait
mais face aux vite elle a dû accepter en
définitive le compromis après une longue
discussion au cours de laquelle les
atmosphères et de tête à certains
moments très proche de la rupture il a
été décidé de réunir le conseil européen
nouvelle fois pour examiner si une
solution pouvait être trouvée devant
accepter dois vous le dire de principe
d'une telle réunion parce que quelques
minutes de la fin des délibérations
madame thatcher a indiqué qu'elle se
rendrait une telle réunion dans un
esprit de compromis
enfin je crois que ce qui a été
important cours de cette réunion c'est
qu'il était tout à fait clair que les
huit pays de la communauté avait une
attitude qu au vu d'un cet égard que
suivant le port allemand l'ampleur de
leurs ressources il était ouvert à plus
ou moins de générosité dans la recherche
des solutions mais ils ont gardé à tout
instant une attitude commune et je crois
que la grande bretagne aura mesuré dans
cette circonstance qu'il existe
véritablement un comportement communauté
et la question qu'il se pose est de
savoir si elle est décidée à adopter en
fuite a respecté ce comportement
communautaire est dur et lorsqu'on a
parlé à la fin
ça te fera parler de l'esprit de
compromis pour aborder le prochain
conseil c'était une première démarche
dans le sens de l'esprit comme nous
faudra naturellement en apprécier
l'ampleur
alors attendons la suite les
conséquences éventuelles en france par
exemple de ce qui vient de se passer à
dublin et puis le prochain sommet en
février à 00h01 vous paierez plus cher
l'essence le gasoil le fioul domestique
et le gaz
c'est la conséquence logique de
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole brut
le 1er octobre dernier
c'est selon les produits la troisième ou
la quatrième est rose de l'année une
prochaine hausse est d'ailleurs prévue
en janvier 80 jean françois robin et va
vous donner le détail de ces hausses qui
aurait pu être d'ailleurs plus
importante si la hausse du dollar
n'était pas venu atténue les choses et
si le franc ne s'était pas tenue aussi
bien comme l'a dit raymond barre tout à
l'heure il est vrai que si le dollar
n'avait accusé une nouvelle baisse
depuis la hausse du pétrole brut
l'essence aurait augmenté d'au moins 5
centimes nous nous contenterons sans
regret de ne payer dès ce soir que trois
centimes de plus le litre
cela nous met tout de même le super à 3
francs 08 l'essence à 287 le gazole à
deux francs 0 3 ces prix de référence
sont ceux de la région parisienne en
province ils sont parfois très
légèrement inférieur pour le fioul
domestique plus 3,1 centimes soit un
franc 222 le litre c'est le gaz
domestique qui augmente le plus de 9,3
pour cent le gouvernement répercutent
les hausses des importations et anticipe
sur les 11 prévus à la production pour
l'année la facture aura été lourde +15
7% pour l'essence +16 3% pour le gaz +37
3% pour le fuel rien pour l'électricité
aujourd'hui mais le relèvement du prix
du pétrole ne manquera pas de se faire
sentir prochainement
on parle du début de l'année dès que les
sapins de noël se seront éteints
une fois de plus c'est tout un peuple
qui est dans la rue à téhéran c'est le
grand deuil chiite de l'achoura une
manifestation d'une ampleur inimaginable
aussi importante sinon plus que lors du
retour de khomeiny à téhéran
la révolution sans cesse attisée par ses
dirigeants une révolution qui se nourrit
d'elle même d'ailleurs et qui oblige
peut-être les ayatollahs et les mollahs
à être plus révolutionnaire que prévu se
moque encore pour l'instant de toutes
les retombées internationales
éventuelles que pourraient lui valoir la
prise d'otages de l'ambassade des états
unis qui en est à son 27ème jour
d'ailleurs c'est décidé l'iran ne sera
pas représenté au conseil de sécurité
des nations unies dont la réunion se
tiendra quand même demain matin sur ces
deux points
notre envoyé spécial raymond girard a
connu aujourd'hui on fait grand défilé
depuis le retour de l'ayatollah khomeini
en février dernier bien que la
commémoration de l'achoura revêt un
caractère essentiellement religieux on
n'avait jamais vu une telle
manifestation populaire à téhéran quatre
millions de personnes sont descendues
dans la rue à l'appel de l'ayatollah
premier league et après la prière
récitée à l'université poule et ce marée
humaine a déferlé dans les principales
artères de téhéran
réaffirmant le droit de tout un peuple
l'excision inconditionnels qui la
portent désormais à l'air vif de rome
antique et événements politiques de la
journée à hisser la conférence de presse
du ministre des affaires étrangères
s'attaque au tchad après avoir annoncé
son refus de rendre à new york devant le
conseil de sécurité des navires les
cocottes dadais a définitivement fermé
des visions qui aurait pu mener à une
négociation
les formules lapidaires une folle les
chats entre l'état ça fait nettement
plus dur fait rentrer des fêtes leurs
valises sabres sont les contrôles
étaient parfois entrevoir une police par
la cnil
avec des plats d'aix d'aucune dimanche
les visaient d'ailleurs de la remise le
peuple iranien irak
c'est à dire 8 à la guerre on a même
l'impression de remise ou l intervention
militaire américaine
les yeux pourrait faire basculer
l'opinion mondiale en faveur de l'iran
cette logique apocalyptique semble
aujourd'hui partagée par des millions
d'êtres humains n'ont apporté arménie
une adhésion totale actuelle
raymond girard et enfin ra une remarque
tout de même après les ce que nous avons
vu des manifestations monstre à téhéran
les manifestations qui sont décrites
comme l'affirmation de l'unité nationale
en iran et bien et qui marque les
célébrations de l'achoura ne se sont pas
passées par tous de la même façon en
dans tout dans tout l'iran par exemple
dans la grande ville de tabriz y ait eu
des incidences en victime précis ce
temps mais c'est peut-être un signe
il ya eu deux défilés différents qui ont
fini par se heurter il y avait un défilé
unitaire et un autre qui ne l'étaient
pas
rien ne dit que la solution du conflit
de plus en plus aiguë entre l'amérique
et l'iran soit le départ du shah de
l'hôpital de new york mais il ne fait
pas de doute que ce sera cela fera
retomber un peu la crise le chat se dit
prêt à partir d'ici quelques jours
on pensait qu'il allait regagner sa
propriété d'acapulco au mexique et puis
l'état mexicain a dit à plusieurs
reprises et qu'il acceptait son retour
mais brusque revirement ce matin le
mexique annonce qu'il ne renouvellera
pas le visa touristique d'un homme qui
est devenu encombrant pour tout le monde
en fait pour tout le monde à deux
exceptions près
l'egypte et éventuellement l'autriche
michel bader
anouar el sadate respecte donc une
parole qu'il avait donnée il ya
longtemps il prouve qu'il n'a pas peur
d'accueillir le char rejetés de partout
y compris parce qu'il accueillait à
l'époque de sa puissance
non seulement le président sadate
accepte cet hôte encombrant mais encore
il propose de mettre son avion personnel
à la disposition de l'empereur démis
pour le faire venir en échec
c'est sans aucun doute un geste
politique de la part du chef de l'état
égyptien qui ne semble guère redouté et
l'a d'ailleurs déjà prouvé la colère ou
les affrontements avec certains pays
frères arabes
de leur côté les iraniens font une
analyse différente de la situation
en effet le disent à peu près ceci que
le chat partons l'egypte c'est parfait
cela arrange presque nos affaires car ce
geste ne fera qu'accélérer la révolution
en egypte contre ça date
pendant ce temps à new york l'ex
impératrice est venu faire une visite à
son mari
alors que les médecins a déclaré que le
chat était en état de quitter l'hôpital
mais pour quelle destination
on le sait toujours pas faisons le point
maintenant avec 2 min mon berger sur les
dernières complications de la crise
entre l'iran et les états unis à propos
donc du conseil de sécurité et de l'ex
chadi rendent son éventuel départ du
complexe aura pas d'autres termes à
commencer par les que la dispersion des
otages dans la capitale iranienne est la
mienne je n'ai pas confirmé encore enfin
ah non ce n'était pas des situations qui
a déjanté négociations laisse bien peu
d'espoir règlements de la lnr
certains condamnera la voir nous sommes
impatients de l'unité a dit le pape des
catholiques aux orthodoxe de turquie les
théologiens vont maintenant travailler à
cette union des deux églises
c'est ce qu'ont décidé jean paul ii et
d'ifri dimitrios 1er mai ce soir
jean-paul deux rentrants à rome doit
certainement méditer sur le fossé qui
sépare toujours les chrétiens de l'islam
pourtant il a tendu la main aux
musulmans dans ses premiers discours
mais les autorités turques étaient
beaucoup plus préoccupés par la sécurité
même du pape
ce qui a donné à donner lieu à un
spectaculaire déploiement policier
d'ailleurs le moins qu'on puisse dire
est que l'atmosphère et a été nerveuse
exemple cet après midi à ephèse à
proximité de la maison de la vierge
marie
un coup de feu est parti les agents de
sécurité ont aussitôt entouré le pape
heureusement ce n'était qu'un gendarme
qui avait fait tomber son fusil
il est à plaindre d'ailleurs pour cette
maladresse sur la dernière partie de ce
voyage du pape ne trouviez spécial
bernard chevalier la rencontre de jean
paul ii est du patriarche dimitrios
premier constitue une étape historique
dans la recherche de l'union retrouvée
entre 160 millions d'orthodoxes et 700
millions de catholiques
l'annoncé de l'ouverture de
conversations théologiques dès le mois
de mars constitue une étape importante
dans ce processus de retour à l'unité
brisé il y a neuf siècles
c'est en tout cas la ferme intention de
jean paul 2 d'arriver avant l'an 2000 à
6 retrouvailles
le pape s'est même montré impatient de
parvenir à un accord
c'est pourquoi at il précisé il a
précipité ce voyage en turquie
les 31 membres de la commission mixte à
haut prélat français devraient en faire
partie
devront donc dissipé les malentendus
doctrinaux et règlements disciplinaires
qui sont en fait à l'origine de la
désunion des églises le patriarche
demetrios premier s'est félicité quant à
lui de l'activité oecuménique de jean
paul paul 2
visiblement l'oriental est fasciné par
le slave mais les patriarches tout en se
réjouissant du climat de détente et de
prière commune qui présidera ces
conversations théologiques en a profité
pour dénoncer le fanatisme religieux
les guerres de religion au nom de dieu
allusion sans équivoque aux voisins
l'ayatollah khomeini jean paul 2 s'est
engagé à tout mettre en oeuvre pour
cette unité des chrétiens il l'a redit
il ya quelques heures encore à ephèse ce
qui laisse la porte ouverte à d'autres
voyages similaires et à des rencontres
avec des chefs religieux et comme l'idée
d'une union de tous les croyants dieu ce
matin était dans l'air dans ce
patriarcat déçu est est minuscule
orthodoxe protégée par la police
militaire
on peut dire que ce quatrième voyage
jean paul 2 inauguré dans la différence
se termine sur des perspectives
optimistes
plus question pour les chrétiens de
rester séparés s'est écrié jean paul ii
le compte à rebours de la reconstitution
d'une grande famille chrétienne a
commencé ce matin c'est au petit matin
que les députés ont adopté
définitivement la loi sur l'avortement
je dis bien définitivement car on a
finalement renoncé à remettre à l'essai
pour cinq ans la loi et surtout son
application
et cela en dépit des avertissements
solennelle de michel debré par exemple
qui le premier jour du débat regrettait
la banalisation de l'avortement
maintenant la loi est votée il lui reste
encore à être confirmée par le sénat
mais de toute façon à l'évidence la loi
ne réglera pas les problèmes de
conscience de chacun devant une décision
aussi grave et elle suscite cette loi
naturellement de vives réactions chez
les adversaires de l'avortement
on voit d'ailleurs quand leur âme et
conscience les députés de la majorité
ont été très partagés
la loi a été adoptée par 271 voix contre
201 ont voté pour les socialistes et les
communistes sans exception mais
seulement 69 députés de la majorité 45
udf sur 121 et 24 rpr seulement sur 154
quelques modifications ont été apportées
à la loi pendant le débat jakin collins
cette loi comme celle de 1975 permettra
à toute femme qui se considèrent en
situation de détresse
et de demander un avortement celui ci
devrait être pratiquée par un médecin et
en milieux hospitaliers publics ou
privés le délai de dix semaines de vue
la conception est maintenu la femme
devra se soumettre à deux entretiens
séparés de sept jours destiné à
l'informer sur les conséquences de son
acte et observer deux jours
supplémentaires de réflexion entre le
deuxième entretien et l'avortement
un dossier guide lui sera remis
contenant la liste des organismes
susceptibles de l'aider
le directeur du centre d'interruption de
grossesse devra se faire remettre et
garder pendant au moins six mois et
attestation justifiant qu'elle a
satisfait à ces consultations
l'avortement ne sera toujours pas
remboursé par la sécurité sociale les
mineurs célibataire devront encore avoir
l'autorisation de leurs parents mais
elles donneront leurs consentements en
dehors de la présence de ceux ci les
médecins garde la liberté de refuser de
faire des avortements
mais ils devront dans ce qu'a indiqué à
la femme l'adresse d'un centre qui
pratiquent les interruptions de
grossesse des commissions dead à la
maternité seront installées dans toutes
les grandes villes auprès des centres
médico sociaux et des bureaux d'être
sociable les sanctions frappant les
médecins qui pratiquent les avortements
illégaux sont sérieusement aggravées
enfin une délégation parlementaire sera
constituée dans chaque assemblée pour
informer le sénat et l'assemblée de la
politique et des problèmes de la
natalité
en résumé ce qui change vraiment et que
ces dispositions sont à présent
définitive du moins le seront elles
lorsqu'elles ont été adoptés par le
sénat qui doit les examiner à son tour
très prochainement
depuis quelques jours vous recevez sans
doute par la poste les cartes appel
guérir de la fondation pour la recherche
médicale mais si vous ne recevez pas
vous pouvez les trouver dans les bureaux
de poste les pharmacies dans les points
de vente du loto et de la loterie
nationale l'appel guérir est une grande
cause nationale
la carte qui vous est proposé est à
retourner accompagné d'un minimum de 20
francs qui vous donnera droit à une
revue intitulée recherché santé
l'argent collecté ira directement aux
chercheurs c'est promis mais alors
direz-vous pourquoi devons-nous donné
que fait le gouvernement
eh bien l'état finance la recherche
scientifique pour la plus grande partie
mais l'aide privée est importante
le voir dans l'exemple choisi par alain
weiler l'aide privée sert aux chercheurs
aller plus vite par exemple hausse
autant en sautant par dessus les
contraintes administratives à la vln un
milliard trois cent trente millions
c'est la somme que la france consacre
chaque année à la recherche médicale
un milliard trois cent trente millions
pour mieux comprendre les maladies et
apprendre à les guérir un milliard trois
cent trente le tiers seulement du
chiffre d'affaires du site à la régie
des tabacs l'état le contribuable paye
92 et demi pour cent de cette somme les
pour publics alimentent essentiellement
les caisses du centre national de la
recherche scientifique et de l'inserm
l'institut national de la santé et pour
une moindre part sous forme de
subventions l'institut pasteur où
l'institut du radium le financement
privé passe notamment par
l'intermédiaire de la fondation de la
recherche médicale
au total 100 millions de francs
recueillis chaque année une goutte d'eau
mais une goutte indispensable aux dires
des chercheurs tels le professeur dos et
dont les travaux sur l'immunologie ou
rendu possibles les transplantations
d'organes ça coûte cher à recherche en
matière d'immunologie ça coûte
relativement moins cher que la recherche
en physique par exemple
enfin tout de même ça coûte cher surtout
faisons beaucoup de cultures cellulaires
par vous n'avez pas l'impression de
faire appel à la charité publique il ya
des actions dead immédiate qui ne
peuvent être donnés grâce à l'aide
privée dit le professeur dos et un
chercheur obtiendra immédiatement le
gros appareils de prix indispensable à
ces travaux alors qu'il lui faut des
années pour obtenir des circuits
administratifs un appareil comme ce
conteur gamma de 200 mille francs
un dernier détail les dons à des
organismes d'intérêt général sont
déductibles du revenu imposable dans la
limite de 1 % de ceux revue l'état à sa
façon
finances la charité publique a lâché
nier ou et bien on sait désormais où a
été détenu le milliardaire sarthois
monsieur henri lelièvre enlevé par
jacques mesrine il s'agit d'une fermette
située au hameau de breuil à une dizaine
de kilomètres au nord de blois dans le
loir et cher monsieur lelièvre qui s'est
rendu sur place et que vous voyez avec
la police et après midi a reconnu
formellement cette maison où il a été
séquestré pendant 30 séjours
le propriétaire un agriculteur l'avait
louée pour les mois de juillet à un
couple et selon la police il pourrait
s'agir pour l'âge pour la femme de
sylvie jeanjacquot la mine mesrine et
pour les hommes s'agirait peut-être ou
de charles bauer ou de michel chaïef qui
les deux complices de jacques mesrine
les nouveaux missiles stratégiques
français sont au point les derniers
essais sont paraît-il tout à fait
concluant les cinq sous marins
nucléaires et la base du plateau
d'albion seront très vite équipés sont
équipés de ces nouveaux missiles qui
sont à tête nucléaire multiples que
c'est un gros progrès par éthique
aiguilleurs du ciel là il y a trois
faits nouveaux j'ai reçus des dépêches
pendant que roger gicquel parler la cgt
première premier fait nouveau la cgt
réclame l'intervention de monsieur
raymond barre en vue de dénouer le
conflit deuxième fait nouveau la
direction de l'aviation civile menace
les aiguilleurs en grève de sanctions
allant jusqu'à la révocation et
troisième fait nouveau de sénateurs
monsieur fortier rpr monsieur legrand
qui est de la gauche démocratique ont
déposé une proposition de résolution
pour la création d'une commission de
contrôle chargé d'examiner les
conditions de fonctionnement des
services du contrôle de la navigation
aérienne
un mot aussi du conflit d'usinor denain
là la direction a décidé de mettre en
chômage technique tout son personnel ce
soir à 22h40 six confrères journalistes
vont peut-être malheureusement être
licencié à l'aurore pour raison
économique ce qui représente environ la
moitié de l'effectif de la rédaction
alors au micro de bruno masure tout de
suite la réaction d'un syndicaliste on
vient écouter pour l'instant il ne
s'agit que d'un projet il n'y a pas eu
de mise à deux reprises ça comme une
entreprise doit se tenir
7 décembre en ce qui nous concerne toute
façon nous n'accepterons pas ne pouvons
pas accepter ces licenciements car nous
estimons que c'est la politique de la
direction qui est néfaste
disons depuis très longtemps et ne
pouvons pas accepter ces licenciements
elle nous on appelle pour cela toutes
les autorités de l'état pour 16 ans
pêche finalement klein titres
disparaissent et que le pluralisme soit
diminué dans ce pays en quelques
secondes vous allez voir des images
saisissantes il s'agit d'un incroyable
d'un gigantesque accident sur
l'autoroute bologne milan en italie
la nuit dernière en effet en plein
brouillard 400 voitures je dis bien 400
se sont télescopés bilan une centaine de
blessés dans une dizaine assez
grièvement mais seulement quatre morts
-deux merci en tout cas le spectacle
qu'ont découvert au petit matin les
pompiers et les policiers étaient
absolument halluciné et hallucinant vous
pouvez en juger par ces quelques images
109 drogués sont morts d'overdose en 78
en france sont des chiffres communiqués
tout à l'heure par le ministère de
l'intérieur
sachez aussi que dans son rapport sur la
télévision le sénateur jean cluzel
demande la création d'une autorité
publique de l'audiovisuel qui aurait
notamment pour mission de promouvoir la
culture française sur les ondes et sur
les antennes internationales
monsieur cluzel regrette aussi
l'insuffisance de la création française
à la radio et à la télévision y compris
dans le domaine de la chanson
le centre et le sud de la région midi
pyrénées ainsi qu'une bonne partie de
l'aquitaine et du roussillon peuvent
depuis presque deux heures capter tf1 en
couleurs le miracle de la coloration a
eu lieu à 18h30 précises en présence de
notre pdg monsieur jean louis guillot et
de celui de tdf monsieur jean ôta il a
suffit d'appuyer sur un simple bouton à
l'émetteur de pechbonnieu
sa proche banlieue et puis sur grâce à
l'émetteur de toulouse béziers midi sur
le canal 27 queiroz est ce qu'on voit là
une très grande partie du sud ouest
c'est donc voilà roger oui et je dois
dire que heureusement c'est cette
coloration n'a pas été perturbé par des
phénomènes météorologiques tout à fait
extraordinaires qui se produisent en ce
moment est un de ces phénomènes
c'est que l'irlande et l'angleterre ont
été littéralement arrosé par une
véritable tempête de sable oui par une
pluie de sable c'était du sable du
sahara qui était qui étaient venus par
avec les nuages et qui est tombé donc
sur l'irlande et sur l'angleterre et un
spécialiste a estimé qu'ils étaient
tombés comme ça soixante mille tonnes de
sable sur les régions que je viens de
vous citer pour la france comme les
jours précédents le soleil et le
brouillard prédomine sur la france et
les températures sont très variables
d'une région à l'autre à 14 heures on
relevait un degrés à alençon et 22° à
pau quelle différence
demain matin le temps sera nuageux et
passagèrement pluvieux de la bretagne à
la frontière belge en fin de journée
cette zone pluvieuse atteindra l'alsace
la lorraine la bourgogne et la
franche-comté ensuite sur les autres
régions le temps restera brumeux encore
assez froid le matin brouillards parfois
givrants du massif central aux alpes et
nuages abondant près de la méditerranée
belles éclaircies dans la journée sur
ces régions il n'y a pas de doute
beaucoup de français ont pris conscience
comment ne l'aurait-il pas fait du fait
que les économies d'énergie était
nécessaire est même possible des
collectivités commencent à donner
l'exemple je vous cite un cas au hasard
la ville de nantes a renoncé à ses
illuminations de noël les commerçants
ont accepté qu'on remplace les six mille
ampoules électriques prévus par 1500
drapeaux dans les rues nantes aura quand
même donc un air de fête mais ça coûtera
moins cher en énergie sacrifier les
illuminations de noël c'est bien mais ce
qui est mieux c'est d'avoir au niveau
d'une multi avaline une municipalité une
politique globale de l'énergie
beaucoup de communes en france s'en
préoccupent maintenant et ce soir nous
allons citer en exemple la petite ville
de
jonzac dans le sud-ouest 3500 habitants
seulement mais beaucoup de projets et de
réalisations
la chasse au gaspi à jonzac avec
christiane de la cua jonzac petite ville
des charentes maritimes sera t-elle une
championne d'économie d'énergie dans la
compétition qui s'amorce elle paraît
bien placé parce que le pétrole est de
plus en plus cher de plus en plus rares
claude bellot son maire qui est
également professeur de géographie
économique s'est donnée à double
objectif d'abord maîtriser la
consommation d'énergie par de simples
travaux d'isolation sur l'ensemble des
bâtiments les écoles elles ont été
équipés de sondes permettrait elle
conditionne le chauffage en fonction de
la température extérieure dans la
chaufferie un système d'horloge
il interrompt le chauffage dans les
classes en dehors des heures
d'occupation tout en le maintenant dans
les logements
coût de l'opération 120 mille de nos
francs amortissable en deux ans résultat
un budget chauffage réduit de 35%
et puis claude bellot a décidé de mettre
en oeuvre tout le potentiel énergétique
locale son grand projet c'est la
réalisation pour sa file d'un chauffage
urbain par géothermie
une idée qui a pris corps ces dernières
années à partir d'une recherche
pétrolière non positive mais qui a
révélé l'existence d'une nappe d'eau
chaude à 10 700 mètres de profondeur
un dossier en bronze feu vert donné le
forage et commencer le chauffage urbain
par géothermie vous y croyez oui il y
croire est ce que ça va changer quelque
chose dans votre vie oui je pense parce
que ça sera certainement moins onéreux
que le fuel en ce moment qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire comme installation chez
vous à la haye
comme tous les décès les réalisateurs
sont déjà là les assure droit mais là
c'est tout selon la dureté des roches
rencontrer le forage progresse de 80 à
150 mètres en 24 heures
il durera deux mois ici loup en sous sol
doit être à 65° par temps très froid
elle ne donnerait pas un chauffage
suffisant on a donc prévu une chaufferie
polycombustibles alimenté en ordures
ménagères et en paille pour faire
l'appoint
quelle est l'importance de cette nappe
d'eau que vous allez atteindre
cette nappe d'eau est considérable
puisqu'elle recouvre semblablement la
quasi totalité du territoire du bassin
aquitain qui doit faire proxim
hâtivement cinquième du territoire
français vous avez reçu des aides
substantielles pour le financement total
de cette opération qui représente un
investissement de 20 millions de francs
tél nous avons une aide de la communauté
économique européenne nous avons une
aide du mystère l'industrie par
l'intermédiaire du comité géothermie
nous avons une aide également de lagence
pour les économies d'énergie dans le
meilleur des cas quand la ville de
jonzac pourra-t-elle bénéficier du
chauffage avant septembre 1980
normalement c'est un immense pari sur
l'avenir qui se joue ici
utopie ses formes d'énergie non pas la
géothermie a déjà fait ses preuves en
islande en hongrie et même au cours
d'expériences dans le bassin parisien
reste à dresser un inventaire des
ressources géothermiques en france oui
vous verrez qu'un jour dans un village
en cherchant de l'eau chaude on trouvera
du pétrole et on ne sera même pas quoi
en faire
c'est une blague bonne soirée à tous et
à toutes au nom de toute l'équipe de tf1
actualité joseph poli vous présentera le
dernier journal en fin de programme
merci